hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show so the last time i spoke about the
coronavirus
i said this i said to myself that i
wasn't going to do
another video on the coronavirus because
mainly reading all the news
pretty much terrified me and so i'm
still pretty terrified
but on this channel i like to talk about
science and there's a lot of really cool
science
and research coming out on the
coronavirus
and so one particular article caught my
eye
and say we're going to talk about it in
this video and so what this article was
trying to address
was why certain populations such as the
elderly are more vulnerable to
coronavirus infection
and it relates this vulnerability to a
mechanogenomic regulation
so in this video we'll talk all about
that and my interpretation of this
article
which actually isn't really an article
it's a comment so there's no
like recent data but it discusses
previous data and
comes up with its own hypothesis to
explain this but firstly let's just
describe what the coronavirus is
so coronaviruses belong to a family of
positive strands
rna viruses and through infection of
their hosts they can cause
upper respiratory tract illnesses such
as odds which is the acute respiratory
distress syndrome and so sars cough
ii is the coronavirus that is currently
causing this current pandemic
of the covered 19 and so what we've
unfortunately witnessed in this most
recent outbreak
is that coronaviruses are potentially
highly
infectious and not only is it highly
infectious but it also can have
considerable
fatality rates as we've also evidently
seen
however these fatality rates are
particularly high
in high-risk groups that include the
elderly and
others with underlying chronic medical
conditions
and this has a huge impact on the
economy and poses a really great burden
on the healthcare services
but the question is is why why do they
have such a high risk of
infection and then fatality
so currently the main hypothesis for why
this would be the case
is that these high risk groups um
have a dysfunction of the immune system
which makes them more susceptible to
infection
and then their ability to deal with the
situation but what was described in this
comment article
is an alternative hypothesis or one that
could also go
in combination which is an altered
cellular mechanical state
and so what this refers to is the
differences in the cell's response to
their surrounding environment
so to give an analogy let's say i'm
surrounded by two sponges that are
moving
towards me maybe not too bad a situation
but put two concrete walls besides me
that i'm even closer together
and i might not be too happy so you see
my response has changed because the
environment is different
and as strange as that analogy probably
was the same can be said for cells
cells reside in tissue and they're
surrounded by other cells but they're
also surrounded by
an extracellular matrix and cells need
to be able to
interact with and respond to changes in
its environment
to be able to survive and to help
prevent the cell from going broke
and causing cancers so the point i'm
trying to make is that cells effectively
talk to their environment
and their surroundings but not only do
they do this by
chemical signals but they can also
interact and communicate through
mechanical signals and it's the
conversion of mechanical signals to
biochemical signals that can propagate
within the cell
is referred to as mechanotransduction so
i'm planning on doing a future video
where i go into a bit more detail about
mechanic transduction because it is
really interesting and i've read a lot
about it recently regarding
an overlap with my phd project but for
now i'll just give a kind of
generic overview to what really is
mechanic transduction
and what is meant by mechanogenomic
regulation
so what i'm drawing out here is the
extracellular matrix
which i said is what surrounds these
cells and so then i've drawn out the
cell membrane
and so this is the barrier to the cell
and then what i've drawn on the bottom
here is the cell nucleus which contains
the dna
that contains the different genes that
are regulated and expressed within a
cell
and so what you can see is at the
membrane there are certain receptor
proteins that can actually interact with
the ecm the extracellular matrix
and through a mechanism that i won't
describe here it can also
interact through to the nucleus and
transmit signals that can
alter the gene expression patterns and
so
these gene expression changes the cell's
responses
can differ depending on the stiffness of
the ecm such as in my analogy
between the sponge and concrete so what
does this have to do with the
coronavirus
well if we think about what the
coronavirus wants to do
it's programmed to make more copies of
itself
and to make more copies of itself it
exploits its host
and it so therefore it exploits the
machinery that's
in the human cells but critical to its
success it wants to do this such that
it's undetected
and so previous work and i just want to
point out here that the references i've
used i've put
the links to the papers in the
description box
have emphasized the use of the nf kappa
b pathway
in this process so what is the nf kappa
b
process well nf cavity is a protein and
it does a lot of things in the cell but
one thing that it does is it
can promote an inflammatory response and
so this response can bring in the immune
cells that can then destroy and kill
infected cells
but studies have also shown that this
protein
and its response can also be activated
by the coronavirus
to promote its replication but how would
this work if the coronavirus wants to
remain undetected
well as i said the n of kappa b pathway
does a variety of things
and so what is now thought is that the
chronovirus actually fine-tunes this
pathway
and so this means that it can still
replicate but still try and remain
undetected so what has this got to do
with age
well the coronavirus largely infects the
lungs and the respiratory system
in aging individuals is characterized by
fibroblast dysfunction
this can result in increased deposition
of the extracellular matrix
and increase the tissue stiffness and
going back to what we said earlier
cells respond differently when they're
witness to
different stiffnesses in their
surrounding environment
and one pathway that can be altered
through a different
stiffness of tissue is the nf kappa b
pathway
so does the virus exploit this such that
it can
infect cells that are in a stiffer
environment
so if you take some cells that are
growing on either a soft or a stiff
matrix and you expose them both to the
same
inflammatory signal you see that they
both activate the inner kappa b pathway
but they both have differences in the
downstream genes
from the nf kappa b that are expressed
and so just imagine that those different
genes are currently within
that purple circle now the interesting
part
is that if you also take a list of genes
that are differently expressed by
coronavirus infection
there's a substantial overlap between
these genes
so genes are expressed differently
depending on the mechanical states i.e
if it's soft or stiff could have some
interaction on impact on the coronavirus
infection
and so this overlap is actually quite
large and
therefore it's interesting to look at
these genes that are affected by both of
them
and to see if we can learn anything from
that so
it seems that most of these genes have
important immune modulatory effects
and so it could be that the chronovirus
can exploit the vulnerability of cells
in a stiffer environment
and improve their chances of replication
without the cells knowing that they're
there
so as i said this is currently just the
hypothesis but i think it could have
important implications not only for the
coronavirus but for understanding other
viral infections
so i hope you learned something and as
always thanks for listening